nous n'avons pas d'à priori mais nous
examinons les situations au cas par cas
nous les examinons au cas par cas y
compris la liste et nous examinons la
situation en fonction des peines qui ont
été prononcés pour le moment nous
n'évoquons pas la mystique mais en
fonction des colonnes à enfumer randy
alessandri qui ont assassiné le préfet
erignac faisant nous sommes sans vous
envisageriez une amnistie
je viens je sais que je vais m'élancer
sur l axe prix pas exprimé j'ai dit que
pour le moment la question de la miss
teen n'avait jamais été envisagée
d'accord je suis en train de vous dire
que nous examinons les situations au cas
par cas
autrement dit je nous nous sommes
récemment interrogé sur la situation
d'un thé plus que nous envisageons de
rapatrier en corse parce que les
conditions le permettent
mais nous examinons les conditions de
sécurité dans lesquelles ils pourraient
être accueillis en c3 j'en ai pas vous
donner ici les trois que je ne voulais
pas ici donner de noms mais en c3 où je
ne sens pas si plaignons pas ici a
précisé je vous dis simplement que nous
sommes récemment agréé par beaucoup
d'autres de toute façon y sont
stationnés sont très peu nombreux mais
il y en a donc nous nous interrogeons au
cas par cas sur la situation qui nous
permettraient ou non d'effectuer ce
rapatriement en corse mais nous restons
dans le cadre de la peine qui a été
prononcée dans le cadre de la
possibilité d'effectuer ce rapatriement
dans le cadre d'un rapprochement
familial
bref comme pour l'ensemble des autres
détenus nous traitons s'est situé bien
détenus corses en seraient concernés
cette réflexion à 4 ou 5 x 4 ou 5 oui
l'heure